We were excited by these results, but then Jim stood up,
and what occurred was truly remarkable.
All the natural biomechanics mediated by the central nervous system
emerged via the synthetic limb
as an involuntary, reflexive action.
All the intricacies of foot placement during stair ascent --
(Applause)
emerged before our eyes.
Here's Jim descending steps,
reaching with his bionic toe to the next stair tread,
automatically exhibiting natural motions
without him even trying to move his limb.
Because Jim's central nervous system is receiving the proprioceptive signals,
it knows exactly how to control the synthetic limb in a natural way.
Now, Jim moves and behaves as if the synthetic limb is part of him.
For example, one day in the lab,
he accidentally stepped on a roll of electrical tape.
Now, what do you do when something's stuck to your shoe?
You don't reach down like this; it's way too awkward.
Instead, you shake it off,
and that's exactly what Jim did
after being neurally connected to the limb for just a few hours.
What was most interesting to me
is what Jim was telling us he was experiencing.
He said, "The robot became part of me."
Jim Ewing: The morning after the first time I was attached to the robot,
my daughter came downstairs and asked me how it felt to be a cyborg,
and my answer was that I didn't feel like a cyborg.
I felt like I had my leg,
and it wasn't that I was attached to the robot
so much as the robot was attached to me,
and the robot became part of me.
It became my leg pretty quickly.
Hugh Herr: Thank you.
(Applause)
By connecting Jim's nervous system bidirectionally
to his synthetic limb,
neurological embodiment was achieved.
I hypothesized that because Jim can think and move his synthetic limb,
and because he can feel those movements within his nervous system,
the prosthesis is no longer a separate tool,
but an integral part of Jim, an integral part of his body.
Because of this neurological embodiment, Jim doesn't feel like a cyborg.
He feels like he just has his leg back,
that he has his body back.
Now I'm often asked
when I'm going to be neurally linked to my synthetic limbs bidirectionally,
when I'm going to become a cyborg.
The truth is, I'm hesitant to become a cyborg.
Before my legs were amputated, I was a terrible student.
I got D's and often F's in school.
Then, after my limbs were amputated,
I suddenly became an MIT professor.
(Laughter)
(Applause)
Now I'm worried that once I'm neurally connected to my limbs once again,
my brain will remap back to its not-so-bright self.
(Laughter)
But you know what, that's OK, because at MIT, I already have tenure.
(Applause)
I believe the reach of NeuroEmbodied Design
will extend far beyond limb replacement
and will carry humanity into realms
that fundamentally redefine human potential.
In this 21st century,
designers will extend the nervous system into powerfully strong exoskeletons
that humans can control and feel with their minds.
Muscles within the body can be reconfigured
for the control of powerful motors,
and to feel and sense exoskeletal movements,
augmenting humans' strength, jumping height and running speed.
In this 21st century, I believe humans will become superheroes.
Humans may also extend their bodies
into non-anthropomorphic structures, such as wings,
controlling and feeling each wing movement within the nervous system.
Leonardo da Vinci said, "When once you have tasted flight,
you will forever walk the earth with your eyes turned skyward,
for there you have been and there you will always long to return."
During the twilight years of this century,
I believe humans will be unrecognizable in morphology and dynamics
from what we are today.
Humanity will take flight and soar.
Jim Ewing fell to earth and was badly broken,
but his eyes turned skyward, where he always longed to return.
After his accident, he not only dreamed to walk again,
but also to return to his chosen sport of mountain climbing.
At MIT, Team Cyborg built Jim a specialized limb for the vertical world,
a brain-controlled leg with full position and movement sensations.
Using this technology, Jim returned to the Cayman Islands,
the site of his accident,
rebuilt as a cyborg to climb skyward once again.
(Crashing waves)
(Applause)
Thank you.
Ladies and gentlemen, Jim Ewing, the first cyborg rock climber.
(Applause)